und was für ein perfektes timing meine
damen und herren
passend zur letzten folge vor unserer
sommerpause gibt es tolle nachrichten
aus mallorca
die deutschen dürfen wieder rein gut
erst mal nur ein paar tausend quasi als
vorhut und versuchskaninchen aber
immerhin immerhin an denen werden dann
ab montag die ganzen anti corona
maßnahmen getestet zum beispiel auch
diese neuen schutzmasken die sie extra
für mallorca touristen entwickelt haben
hier sehen wir gerade wie der
versuchsleiter die maske mit
desinfektionsmittel befüllt nein
nehmt das wären ja nur wir deutschen
dürfen auf die insel keine festland
spanier keine engländer was da plötzlich
für gelände würde möglich sind wahnsinn
da ist eine riesenchance ist eine
riesenchance
zumindest innerhalb der eu wird also
wieder etwas mehr gereist und das ist
eine richtig gute nachricht für die
deutsche tourismusbranche die natürlich
brutal unter corona leidet wir haben
seit 16
märz arbeiten wir durchgehend um alles
abzuwickeln um alle stornierungen
abzuwickeln wir müssen provisionen
zurückzahlen müssen unten gelder
zurückzahlen
und das war einnahmen 0 und das ist
betriebswirtschaftlich eine schlechte
rechnung schlag das mal kurz nach in
betriebswirtschaft für dummies 0 1
nahmen große ausgaben ist richtig ist
nicht gut
ja die reisebüros stehen für 100000
arbeitsplätze kriegen zwar etwas mehr
hilfe aus dem neuen konjunkturpaket der
bundesregierung aber das ist wohl nur
sagen die ein tropfen auf den heißen
stein
zumal viele deutsche wissen sie diesen
sommer ja zu hause bleiben im urlaub und
um da als reisebüro trotzdem noch was zu
verdienen
da musst du dir etwas einfallen lassen
wie sonst in afrika organisieren sie
jetzt reisen in der mecklenburgischen
seenplatte lassen sich auch am siemens 1
falko safari fand das mal ganz witzig
kuh safari da ist an der bauer der fährt
mit dem kunden dann einfach über
seinfeld und die fahren zu den kühen ist
eine klasse idee oder
der fachmann spricht hier von coupon
warum nicht ohne nicht man muss das
ganze einfach nur aggressiv bewerben
vergessen sie den krüger-nationalpark
buchen sie jetzt ihre safari bei bauer
krüger in sandbostel staunen sie über
niedersachsens exotische tierwelt wir
haben echte zebras nashörner elefanten
und natürlich den könig der tiere
und wer traut sich die exotische küche
der eingeborenen zu probieren ich nicht
traumurlaub im baur krüger-nationalpark
sandbostel genau zwischen wertstoffhof
und kläranlage ist doch super ist doch
super
den kreativen kleinen reisebüros denen
müsste der staat viel mehr helfen
stattdessen wird im märz als erster
deutscher konzern überhaupt ausgerechnet
die tui gerettet mit 1,8 milliarden euro
dann hätten die kleinen auch gerne
verstecken mit tui zu den großaktionären
von tui gehört unter anderem eine
russische oligarchen familie und die
spanische hotelkette riu der teufel
scheißt eben immer auf den größten
haufen aktuell ein großes tui problemen
kein mensch bucht gerade mehr
kreuzfahrten als tatsache auf der ganzen
welt liegen die fetten pötte vor anker
und die arme besatzung darf oft gar
nicht mehr von bord wann gibt's wieder
kreuzfahrten wir bereiten uns im
augenblick darauf vor dass wir mini
kreuzfahrten oder schnupper kreuzfahrten
von deutschland nach deutschland ab
juni/juli anbieten cool von deutschland
nach deutschland
da wollte ich immer mal hin ich meine
klar irgendwas musst du schon machen mit
den kreuzfahrtschiffen diesen
schwimmenden plattenbauten hier neue
folge vom traumschiff
meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen auf der ms corona ich freue
mich auf eine spannende reise und da
sind wir auch schon
auf der anderen rheinseite in remagen
das war's vom traumschiff danke für ihre
gebühren gute nacht
von einer länge her meine absolute
lieblingsfarbe
wir halten wir fest vor allem den großen
wird hier geholfen und das gilt auch für
die lufthansa haben sie das mitgekriegt
sie haben sich gerade eine airline
gekauft ja also der peter hier hat das
für sie unterschrieben mit 9 milliarden
steigt unser staat ein bei lufthansa ist
voll das schnäppchen denn der börsenwert
des frisch aus dem dax geflogenen
kranichs beträgt nicht mal die hälfte
immer wie blödsinn 49 milliarden für
gerade mal 20 prozent anteil und so gut
wie kein echtes mitspracherecht damit
keiner meckert wenn lufthansa demnächst
bis zu 22.000 stellen streicht während
der verhandlungen hat der lufthansa chef
der spur wo sogar gedroht ins sogenannte
schutzschirm verfahren zu gehen dann
werden sämtliche bereits bezahlte
tickets der kunden wertlos gewesen sind
quasi erpresser methoden für mich sind
das erpresser mit rund neun milliarden
unter anderem für euro wings eine
fluglinie die immer nur rote zahlen
schreibt das kommt nämlich von der
ganzen böden billigfliegerei zunächst
war es der snack jetzt streicht die
lufthansa tochter euro wings ihren
passagieren die spucktüten die bei
übelkeit zum einsatz kommen
in zukunft soll es nicht mehr eine tüte
pro sitz sondern nur noch eine tüte pro
reihe geben
macht nichts reicht doch man soll ja in
corona zeiten in die armbeuge kotzen
wissen sie ich sage ihnen jetzt mal wen
wir retten müssten als steuerzahler als
staat die deutsche jugendherberge ist
ausdrücklich kein witz die
jugendherberge ist hochgradig existenz
bedroht schulausflüge zum beispiel
finden ja logischerweise nicht mehr
statt jugendherbergen dürfen keinen
profit machen haben also keine rücklagen
aber trotzdem kosten das geht uns jetzt
unmittelbar an die substanz das heißt
wir haben keine weiteren reserven wenn
wir keine unterstützung erfahren
dann kann man zwar anschließend wenn
diese krise vorbei ist wieder zu uns
kommen aber nur in der theorie weil es
uns dann nicht mehr gibt so kommt es zu
einer leeren jugendherberge da muss
wirklich was passieren ernsthaft in
deutschland gibt es allein 442
jugendherbergen plus natürlich den
ganzen schullandheime die deutsche
jugendherberge für mich mindestens
unesco-weltkulturerbe dahin
so viele wunderbare erinnerungen dran
rettet die jugendherberge max mutzke
sind die 100 schönsten herberg sitz mit
klassikern wie dem hagebuttentee song
macht doch ne kann hagebuttentee den
gibt's nur hier in der jugendherberge
niemand trinkt sonntage wurden
den gibt es nun
tanz ab zur techno version von zahnpasta
auf der türklinke vom mädchenzimmer oder
zur ballade vom heimweh krankenbett
leser
peters
leg dich nicht
etage
ich nicke
halt mal dicht
rettet die jugendherberge von jeder
verkauften cd gehen zwei euro direkt
gruppen und dosen ravioli
hagebutten sehr gute aktion übrigens
sind die jugendherbergen von heute
natürlich viel schöner als die meiner
kindheit einfach mal informieren unter
jugendherberge de hunderttausende
deutsche warten derweil immer noch auf
rückerstattung ihrer stornierten reisen
denn viele veranstalter arbeiten
offensichtlich mit einer muss man so
sagen unverschämten hinhaltetaktik bei
den verbraucherzentralen gehen deswegen
täglich tausende beschwerden ein
wir schalten live zu albrecht humboldt
er leitet das gemeinsame storno call
center der deutschen reisebranche
humboldt stimmt das wollen sie die
kunden möglichst lange hinhalten quatsch
hinhalten also das weise ich entschieden
zurück der kollege und ich wir tun hier
alles was menschenmöglich ist das nervt
sekunden ich muss mein technisches
problem lösen so viel besser wie war die
frage mehr
selbst große konzerne haben monatelang
versucht den kunden gutscheine
aufzudrängen dabei sagt die europäische
fluggastverordnung ganz klar lufthansa
und co müssen das geld nach spätestens
sieben tagen zurück überweisen
was heißt denn hier auf drängen wir
haben einfach versucht den kunden
behutsam die vorzüge der gutscheinlösung
nahe zu bringen
du nimmst jetzt in gutschein es gibt
kein geld zurück du gierige alte
fregatte und ruf nie wieder hier an ja
herrgott der branche steht das wasser
bis zum hals warum soll uns der kunde
dann nicht mal einen zinslosen kredit
geben für die paar monate bis jahre also
ich hab gelesen
auf mehreren webseiten der veranstalter
war der hinweis auf die rückerstattung
wir müssen sehr gut versteckt ist
völliger unsinn hier beispiel die seite
von easyjet da habe ich die buttons
umbuchen gutschein und gut sichtbar
rückerstattung also ich muss dazu sagen
der button das im moment leider kaputt
aber mein kollege hier arbeitet schon
dran aber wo ich sie gerade dran habe
ein ryanair-flug morgen nach lissabon
der fällt aus da hätte ich gerne mein
geld zurück
ja kein problem da schicken sie einfach
eine e mail an arsch lecken ryanair de
und dann haben sie garantiert nächste
woche ihren gutschein in der posten ja
ich will aber keinen gutschein bitte ich
an sie und ganz schlecht stehen
technisch ist eben tut mir leid ist das
albern albrecht humboldt albrecht hung
beugt so die letzte heute show vor der
sommerpause und da ist es natürlich das
mindeste wenn wir schon so lange vom
schirm verschwinden heute schon
abzuarbeiten was in den nächsten wochen
passieren wird traditionell an dieser
stelle ein job für dietmar wischmeyer
kinder wird dieser sommer toll
lockerungen wohin man blickt in
thüringen zum beispiel ist beim sex mit
mehr als drei personen aus vier
haushalten erlaubt der ramelow heißt ja
nicht umsonst so und wir alle dürfen
wieder raus aus deutschland mallorca
lässt ein kontingent teutonen auf den
ballermann und um die ansteckungsgefahr
im flieger zu minimieren werden vor dem
start alle passagiere in folie
eingeschweißt auf malle lohnt das
entfernen das ganzkörper kondom es
eigentlich kaum einfach rotwein cola
oben rein kippen und langsam nach unten
laufen im juli spitzt sich der
machtkampf in der afg zu nach kalbitz
rauswurf und dem ende des flügels
gründet bernd hocke eine neue
sammlungsbewegung kritischer faschisten
den sogenannten schwanz ein
programmatisches werk rechtsträger aus
überzeugung wird daraufhin zur
bettlektüre der nationalen erhebung im
august mit dem start des neuen
schuljahrs ist immer noch homeschooling
angesagt beim statistischen bundesamt
werden die armen schüler mittlerweile
als alleinerziehende geführt mütter sind
mit den nerven am ende und väter bereuen
den tag als sie die durchtrennung ihrer
samen strenge abgesagt haben
unterdessen denken die kultusminister
über grundlegende reform nach den anfang
macht bremen mit dem neuen fach
verschwörungstheorien
als alternative zum religionsunterricht
hier eine online vorlesung von doktor
attila hildmann liebe freunde demokraten
patrioten und deutsch nationalisten wir
haben es offenkundig bykow mit einer
kommunistischen bedrohung zu tun
offenkundig und die schwerkraft ist eine
erfindung von bill gates und noch eine
gute nachricht die amerikanische
demokratie wird nun doch nicht
abgeschafft donald trump verliert im
november die wahl und willigt ein das
oval office nach einer übergangszeit von
nur vier jahren zu räumen
dann ist joe biden allerdings schon 102
und die allerbeste nachricht zum schluss
ab montag gibt es die deutsche corona
von jens spahn beworben mit den slogans
hfc leine du solche und app dafür
ich weiß wo deine viren sind und was
kann die
blinken und piepsen wenn einem eine
andere corona entgegenkommt ja und sonst
nichts wie gesagt ist eine deutsche
software entwicklung in diesem sinne
schönen sommer bleiben sie vermummt
hallo leute ich bin der heute show
nehmen ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
scheiß und liegt - wollt dann abonniert
jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist niemand der stelle
[Musik]